Bob your book is make film history yes
right you said it came out about a year
and a half ago yes so which chapter from
your book is the most important in your
opinion and why if you had to choose I
know their first among equals or but but
what if you had to choose one chapter
that you feel is really the essence of
the book and what any 25 year old if
they could spend one hour reading
something put their phone down for one
moment what chapter do you think would
be the most file in your book of life oh
gosh that is a really hard hard question
and well I guess I might be the one
where I just explained with classical
cutting is because it's a fundamental
sort of two of everything we're done
with DW Griffith and his discovery of
classically cutting the scene because
that's the basic vocabulary of
filmmaking you know establishing shot
detail shot close-up get out of it this
way of organizing things I guess that
that would be the most important one if
you only could read one but there's so
many of them that seemed to me seemed to
be crucial on chapter on jungle guitar
and breathless I think is extremely
worthwhile because it enables you to see
the connection between somebody's
personality and their way of making a
movie you know in that chapter that the
book is a kind of a hybrid and that's
what sort of unusual about it there's
the book and there's also the web page
and so in the book you read the
description like books described and
then you go to the web page and their
various kind of resources with sing and
dance but finally you get some film
footage to work with and when you work
with the footage in many cases you're
working with clips from classic movies
or else in this particular case the one
from breathless we shot some footage of
our own to emulate a scene from
breathless and you know you begin to
sort of see what the effect of jump
cutting or not jump cutting the scene is
so I'd say it's really hard for me to
pick anyone
old chapter but I think the really
crucial thing to do is to read the book
and then mess with the exercises
whatever your level of filmmaking skill
is because the point of my book which
makes it different than other books is
that I'm going at this from the point of
view of a creative person you know my
idea in writing this book was that I
wasn't going to simply dryly tell this
happened that happened that happened
that happened and so on but I'm inviting
people to sort of imagine themselves in
the middle of the creative universe and
see if they can't discover what they
would do given the same kind of problem
and solve it for the first time gaddar
in breathless I started jump cutting
because he had a practical problem the
movie was too long I was going to do and
so he simply said hey let's just cut and
that's what they did and that sheer sort
of necessity created a whole feel and
Gestalt for the film so while it's hard
for me to pick out any single chapter I
would say the crucial thing to do is to
go to the webpage and win it with the
book and that's different than most film
history books up to this point most of
the film history books they're wonderful
and their area diet and their learning
and their broad and their deep but what
they are is connected to the experience
of making movies yourself my book is
sort of for people who would like to
think that they have within it
themselves to make a movie or to at
least think like a filmmaker release to
understand what filmmakers are thinking
and so that's the crucial thing it's not
that any particular chapter is crucial
it's that joining the book and the
exercises in the webpage that's the
important thing
you